Hello everyone my name is Rowan and Donovan and I'm in the field working on a story in northern Rwanda about mountain gorillas
Hiking at 11,000 feet is not easy
We've so far gone up 3,000 feet since we started
Thicker stuff about 11,500 feet now
So we found the Grylls we have eyes on them but
They're gonna side of this ravine, and there's one up towards the skyline they're
Gonna be tricky
So dingo tracking this morning we just found two snares
Felix is cutting the bamboo rod so that it can't be used again
So really close to the grills we can hear them chest pounding just over here in the bushes
And we can see this trail that they used to go up the side of the ravine
Okay, we just found the gorillas
Well that's it for today folks, thanks again for following along with me here in Rwanda
I hope you enjoyed seeing the mountain gorillas. I know I did